Even though I walk through the valley of the shadow
of death, I will not fear for you are with me.
You are my light and my salvation.
You restore me and lead me for your glory.
I long to dwell in your house forever.
Amen. Well, good morning church. You can have a seat.
So glad to see you all today.
Had a great couple weeks of camps.
Now we're gearing up for the semester.
I'll go ahead and invite you to take your copy of God's Word
and turn with me to Psalm 75.
So what we're gonna be all morning,
I'll explain more here in a moment.
We're continuing our journey, long journey
through the book of Psalms.
And, and you may not be aware of this,
but uh, there are 150 psalms in the
Book of Psalms.
Uh, so kids, let's give a little bit of a math refresher
before we get back into school.
Uh, what is half of 157? 5 75.
Okay, good. We're already on track.
Ready to start school again.
And so us being in Psalms 75 today means
we are halfway through the entire book of Psalms.
Halfway dressed up by the way.
So, uh, you can see like it,
it only took us five years to get here.
How about that? Uh, we'll see
how long it takes us to finish.
But here's what we're gonna do today.
So this is something we've seen a number
of times already in various songs
where you look at the heading and it says something like To
the choir master or it says a song.
In fact, this one says both of those things
and it means that even like this one is attributed to ASAP
and his family was the worship leaders at the temple,
leading the people in singing praises to God.
And so you put all that together
and what that means that these psalms were meant
to be sung by.
All right, the choir master a song.
In fact, all of them were really prayers slash
songs that we can sing.
But, but this one specifically and many others say that.
And so that's what we're going to do today.
We're not gonna do it with every psalm
that says choir, master or song.
We won't do that all the time. But today
what we're gonna do is we're gonna sing these truths
as we work through the psalm, just as a way
to practice what they would've done.
I'm gonna teach for a little bit and then we'll sing
and then I'll teach some more and then we'll sing
and it just kinda works through and you'll see it as we go.
And so as we sing, I would invite you
to keep your Bibles open right there at your seat.
Keep your notes out if you take notes and,
and just be ready to go the whole time
'cause we're gonna bounce back and forth.
But also be ready to stand up if you are able and
and praise together and sing these same truths to God.
And you'll again, you'll see what we mean as we go.
I wanna pray first, then we'll get into God's word.
Lord, we thank you for the time we get to
to be here together today.
We don't take it for granted that we get to be
worshiping you freely.
Uh, we know that many people
around the world don't have that privilege.
And so we're grateful
and we don't wanna take that lightly or for granted.
So we pray that we can by your spirit's power respond to you
and faith and joy and praise 'cause you're worthy.
Then we would give our lives as a response to all
that you've done and all that you are.
Help us Holy Spirit, open our eyes to see
what you want us to see today.
Understand it, apply it, live it out in Jesus' name. Amen.
I wanna read the 10 verses of Psalm 75.
First get a feel for where we're going
and then we'll come back and work through it.
So Psalm 75, again, the heading is
to the choir master according to do not destroy,
which would've been maybe a melody, a tune, a a way
of singing it, A Psalm of asap, A PS song
verse one, we give thanks to you.
Oh God, we give thanks for your name is near.
We recount your wondrous deeds.
At the set time that I appoint, I will judge with equity.
When the earth tots
and all its inhabitants, it is I
who keeps steady it's pillars.
Sayah, I say to the boastful, do not boast
and to the wicked, do not lift up your horn.
Do not lift up your horn on high or speak with haughty
or prideful neck for not from the east or from the west
and not from the wilderness comes lifting up.
It is God who executes judgment putting down one
and lifting up another.
For in the hand of the Lord there is a cup
with foaming wine, well mixed.
He pours out from it
and all the wicked of the earth shall
drain it down to the drex.
But I will declare it forever.
I will sing praises to the God of Jacob.
All the horns of the wicked, I will cut off,
but the horns of the wick, righteous shall be lifted up.
Okay, so this song meant to be sung by the congregation.
Notice how it starts. Verse one.
It says, we give thanks to you.
Oh God, we give thanks for your name is near.
We recount your wondrous deeds.
Now that word recount means exactly what you think it means.
It means to go back over to count again
to remember something.
It's like what I used to do when I was a kid
with a huge bag of Skittles.
I would pour out that five pound bag
right on my grandma's table.
Didn't need all of it at one sitting, maybe two. Okay?
So it was all of that right there.
And I would separate them out
and I would put them into football formations.
And I would have one team, the purple team, Dallas Cowboys
of course on this side against the Redskins on the other
side or or the Bengals and the orange team
or whatever, 11 on 11.
And I would've to count 'em out and then I would
play a play.
And then if they got tackled, they got eaten.
Of course, right? So that's what you would do.
And I would have to recount again
and again to make sure at 11
and 11 recounting over and over.
That's what we're talking about here.
As God's people do that, not with Skittles,
but as God's people remember all God has done
as they remember who he is
and what he has done, how good he is to them, how near he is
to them, how he will do certain things in the future,
remembering all of that, they could not at the time help
but announce their gratitude.
Thank you God, thank you for all you are.
Their first response to his wondrous deeds. Thank you God.
Their first response, how good he's been to them,
their first response to the exodus of getting 'em out
of Egypt is like, thank you, we're grateful.
Thank you God. So that's what we're gonna do.
By the way, we recount God's wondrous deeds
every week in here.
We're not just doing it today in a unique way.
We do it by recounting the gospel, the good news,
this reality that we look at the glory of God.
We recount how he is this in his attributes
and that in his works and he's good
and he's just, and we recount that.
We keep reminding each other,
we keep remembering those kind of things.
Remember last week, mark talked about in Psalm 74
the perspective shift.
That's what we're talking about here,
to climb the mountain of who God is.
So we look at the rest of the world
and we understand rightly how to look at the rest
of the world because we look at who God is
and we remember recount that who he really is.
So that's what we're gonna do. Another aspect of the Psalms
that we need to understand is
that they were not collected haphazardly.
They were collated
and placed where they were on purpose by God.
And if you remember last week, Psalm 74 ended
with this unresolved uncertainty about
the way the world was going.
The temple had been destroyed,
the enemies seemed to be winning.
Well, Psalm 75 then placed right
after that is really God's answer to
what was left unresolved in Psalm 74.
And so look again, you'll see it right here verses two
through five.
If you noticed as I was reading through first,
there's quotation marks at the beginning of this.
This is God. Now speaking, watch this.
At the set time that I appoint, I will judge with equity.
When the earth tots
and all its inhabitants, it is I
who keeps steady its pillars.
Sayah, I say to the boastful, do not boast.
And I say to the wicked, do not lift up your horn.
Do not lift up your horn on high or speak with haughty
or prideful neck.
I think one of the most common phrases out
of kids' mouths is that's not fair.
Right? Everybody seen that one before, right?
That's not fair. You've heard that we've said it and
and we all get there.
But it's not just kids, right?
Like there's an inherent sense of justice in all of us
as adults as well.
Whether we've personally experienced the injustice of abuse
or racial profiling
or being cheated in some way, or maybe not us.
But we've watched somebody experience something like that
and we look at this, we like, that's not fair.
All of us say that.
Well what we just read in Psalm 75 is actually
God's response to all that.
He reminded them back then
and he reminds us today that our response should be to trust
God's just sovereignty,
trust his just sovereignty.
Again, remember back then the people were wondering
where God was enemy
after enemy kept ransacking the land,
they destroyed God's temple, they stole away his people.
And they're looking around at this.
And that's why you see over
and over in the Psalms, they're like, God, where are you?
Do you not see God? This is your people. This is your land.
That's your temple. Do you not see what's happening?
Do you even care?
Which honestly can lead us
to temptations of thinking that maybe God isn't real.
People look around and see evil
and they think, well, God's certainly not
real if this is happening.
Or maybe we, okay, God is real, but maybe he's not good.
People wonder if God is good or,
or maybe we think God's just not strong enough
to handle this situation.
This one's outside of his realm.
Or maybe at the very least we think somehow that the evil
and the wicked in the world will somehow get away with it,
their opposition to God.
And it's just like, well, they're just never God.
Nothing's ever gonna happen.
That's why these verses are so critical for us to remember
because God himself says we need
to trust his just sovereignty
whenever we face situations like that.
'cause he says right up, I'm gonna judge with equity.
I will judge with equity.
Meaning he's not gonna play favorites.
Everyone's gonna be judged on the same standard.
No one gets a pass. He's judging everyone equally.
Those who have a prideful, boastful, haughty,
this this arrogant stance, he'll humble 'em.
Those who lift up their horn,
verse 10 says He's gonna cut it off now.
Now we don't understand that metaphor most likely.
So when you see that, there's a bunch
of different ways you could take this,
but maybe just summary.
Think of a rhino.
When somebody's horn is lifted up against
God, think of a rhino.
That horn on the front is a symbol of its power, right?
You don't want to mess with that.
You don't wanna touch that. It's it's power,
it's authority, it's strength.
That's the idea here to lift up your horn is
to lift up your own power.
Claim that you have power, you have authority
that was happening back then.
But again, it's not just back then.
That stuff is just as relevant today.
We watch people every day shake their fist at God,
deny his existence, mock him in any number of ways.
And we look at all of that
and it can feel like evil is winning.
It can feel like things are out of control.
It can feel like God's offline for a while
and everything's just going wild.
Look again at verse three.
When the earth totters,
when it's like a teeter totter, when you're a kid, right?
When it's shaky, when things are going up and down
and all it's inhabitants, not just the earth, everything
included in the earth, all of us, everything seems to be
going wild.
It is I God says, who keeps steady
its pillars say lot.
That word remember stop. Just consider that for a second.
Slow down. Remember when all seems to be out
of control, I'm holding it all together.
When everything seems to be out of whack and it's evil
and wicked and it's you're overwhelmed by it.
God says, no, no, don't forget
I'm holding this thing together.
Nothing is truly out of control. Nothing.
God is sovereign to us. It might feel like it to us.
It might seem like the foundations
of our lives are crumbling
and the pillars of society are falling apart.
It might seem like that to us,
but God is keeping it all together.
It's God who is actually studying it
and it's God who will bring it all to completion.
That's the kind of God that the apostle Paul was able
to write to
and write about Second Corinthians four, eight and nine.
Because God is just because God is right
and God is sovereign.
He could write this. We are afflicted in every way
but not crushed.
We are perplexed but not driven to despair.
We are persecuted but not forsaken.
We are struck down but we're not destroyed.
'cause he knew, he knew God was holding it all together
and it wouldn't be like this forever.
Yet we can't forget something about Psalm 75,
that verse two, look again at the first line,
Psalm 75, verse two.
It says, God says, at the set time that I appoint,
I will judge with equity not on
our timeline, right?
This is his time.
Not when we think God should bring the judgment his time.
No, it's his right time.
We might not fully understand it probably won't,
but it's his right time, his right way.
That's where the trust factor comes in here that we trust.
His ways are right. We trust his timing is right.
I heard it said justice delayed is not the same thing
as justice denied.
Just because it's not happened on our timeline
doesn't mean it's not gonna happen.
He will. It says, I will judge with equity.
That's why we can count on
what Paul wrote in Romans 12 verse 19.
He said, beloved never avenge yourselves
but leave it to the wrath of God for it is written,
vengeance is mine.
I will repay, says the Lord. This is his deal.
It's his time, it's his justice, it's his sovereignty.
We trust him. We trust this holy God who will do
what is right, the sovereign one,
the Lord of the universe forever.
We trust him that he is holy
and he will take care of what he needs to take care of,
his time his way, but he will do it.
So we just saw God speak about this perspective.
Well, Psalm 75 then shifts back
to the author speaking about God
and how he's going to judge And look at verses six
through eight again says, for not from the east
or from the west and not from the
wilderness comes lifting up.
But it is God who executes judgment putting down one
and lifting up another for in the hand of the Lord.
There's a cup with foaming wine, well mixed
and he pours out from it
and all the wicked of the earth shall drain
it down to the dregs.
You see the first part of verse 10 as well, all the horns
of the wicked I will cut off.
And so we just learned we can trust God's sovereignty,
that he's gonna do what's right at his time, his way.
We can trust that. And here we see his justice.
Uh, for those who who claim to be self-made for those
who prop up their own manmade power structure,
it says God will cut off that horn in judgment.
But not even just like self-made like I can do this myself.
It's even anything else the world would promote.
That's what verse six talks about from the east
or the west or the wilderness.
There's nothing in this world.
Nothing is actually what elevates a person to a place
of power or authority.
True exaltation, nothing in the world does that.
It's only from God.
You see it throughout the scriptures.
It's God who appoints leaders of nations
for blessing or for judgment, right?
Sometimes God gives a nation a just right good leader
to bless that nation
and sometimes he gives them a wicked evil leader
to judge that nation.
It's God who raises up.
It's God who puts down
and notice verse eight talks about this, this cup
of well mixed foaming wine.
God is holding from which he pours out
judgment on the wicked of the earth.
Now, what in the world is that even talking about
it's imagery of course.
And what it means though is it's pretty common in the Bible
to see this image pop up that there's a cup of God's wrath.
We see it in places like Jeremiah 25 toward all the nations
that refuse to worship God.
We see it in Habak two toward the Chaldeans
who were defrauding other people.
The cup of God's wrath was poured out on them.
It's all over the book of Revelation.
God's judgment on those who worship false gods,
his cup is poured out.
In fact, let me just show you Revelation 14, verse 10.
He will drink the wine of God's wrath,
poured full strength into the cup of his anger.
He'll be tormented with fire.
And sulfur like that is wrath imagery.
That's judgment imagery.
Now, we don't like talking about this, right?
In fact, people all over deny this.
But the reality is that those who refuse
to worship the one true God will be judged.
It will be final, it will be full, right?
That's the phrase, drain it down to the dregs.
That's what that illustrates. That like you've sucked the
very last drop out of that cup
and that wrath is full and final.
There is nothing left that's coming one day.
Again, for those who live in arrogant defiance
of God's rule in their life, he will pour out the cup
of his wrath on them forever.
Now, for the believer, if you're a believer in Christ
for the believer, there is a measure of of comfort
that comes from that.
Because we do look around in the world
and we see wickedness winning and overcoming and destroying
and hurting and defrauding and,
and this is a measure of comfort
because this says God is going to execute ju justice.
He is going to bring right true judgment.
The wicked won't get away with it in the end.
But there's also a warning here, right?
And the consistent drumbeat of scripture says that those
who oppose God should fear his final judgment.
Anyone who opposes God raises their horn,
their self power authority against him
and refuses the rule of God in their life
should fear God's final judgment.
Because the truth of the matter is
that apart from an intervention every human being is
underneath the wrath of God.
We were born into sin.
We also sin ourselves and that separates us from God.
We fall short of the glory of God.
We are due his judgment
because of that apart from any intervention
that is the destiny of every human.
None are righteous. No one can get out
of his wrath on their own, can get clear
of his wrath on their own.
And I think we just need to stop
and sit on this for a second
and think about this for a moment.
Like there's no song we can sing for this one,
but I think we need to stop and consider it for a second.
So right where you are, just just stop, bow your head.
Consider this reality. Let's just be
quiet in light of this.
And I just, I just want us to think on
God's final judgment that is coming for all
who turn away from him in sin.
Just think about this reality and
and so I'm gonna talk about it in a couple ways.
First, for you, believer, if you are a believer in Christ,
there can be a bit of comfort here
that God will humble those who shake their fist at him,
that his judgment is truly coming, justice is coming.
We know our suffering is not the end of the story.
He will make it all right.
Just rest in that for a second.
Believe her, find some comfort there.
Yet even as we do that, we should never rejoice
at the destruction of the wicked.
So we should also feel at the same time a measure of grief
over sin and urgency
to declare God's gracious works to all
ask him for the urgency.
But I'm also aware that some
of you sitting here are not followers of Christ.
I just wanna say first, thank you for being here.
I don't enjoy having to say these things,
but it's what God said in his word.
So if that's you, I would just invite you
to take all this in to feel the weight
that there is an end coming,
that there is a God we are accountable to,
and that if you continue on the track of self worship
denying God, then this is what your end will look like.
I don't want that for you.
Just consider what God has said here.
But the fact that his judgment is coming
is why we all need to see this last section of Psalm 75.
Because if that judgment truly is coming,
then is there a way out for sinners,
sinners like you and me, where again,
apart from an intervention, every one
of us is headed towards this.
Is there a way out? What's the answer
if this is really bad news?
What's the answer to this?
What's what ASAP alludes to here in verses nine
and 10, remember verse one.
He started by giving thanks recounting God's wondrous deeds
here at the end verses nine and 10.
But I will declare it forever. What's he talking about?
What is it first?
Well, it's what he just said about God's justice.
But there's more to it. I will declare it forever.
I will sing praises to the God of Jacob.
Yes, all the horns, the wicked all be cut, will be cut off,
but the horns of the righteous shall be lifted up.
So what's he declaring here? He's declaring salvation.
He's declaring God's salvation.
But notice he does it in an interesting way.
He declares both God's justice and God's mercy.
He declares justice and mercy of God.
He doesn't just sit around with the choir, the congregation,
and praise God
because we know God's gonna cut the wicked's horn off.
We know that all this is gonna happen.
God's gonna make it right. God's gonna bring justice.
God's gonna humble those who turn away from him.
We're not just gonna sit back and throw stones at them.
He's also saying, no, I'm declaring God's mercy
to his people because he says not only the horns
of the wicked be cut off, the horns
of the righteous shall be lifted up.
I know what you're thinking though. You just heard me
say no one is righteous.
There's not one. Romans three
says, well, on our own.
That's true. Every one
of us on our own judged against the standard of God's glory,
we all fall short of that.
Absolutely none are righteous.
But we read this psalm through the lenses
of Christ, through the lenses of the New Testament
because Romans 3 22 says, the righteousness
of God is manifested through faith in Jesus Christ
for all who believe.
What that means is that God gives us his righteousness.
He makes us righteous.
When we place our faith in Jesus Christ,
when we place our faith in him, he gives us righteousness.
So when he says here, the horns
of the righteous will be lifted up.
That's really Jesus. But we've been made righteous
and we will be lifted up as well.
And so I know man, that conceptually, intellectually
that sounds too simple, like God just can't make this like
just switch it, right?
Because we're guilty in a courtroom,
we would be held as guilty.
So he can't just switch it.
Something has to be done for the sin.
Judgment has to come, payment has to be made.
Something has to be done.
It seems too simple, but here's why.
That's a legitimate solution to our problem.
Remember the cup of God's wrath, Psalm 75,
I want you to listen to what Jesus said to Peter
in the garden the night before he was crucified.
John 1811, Jesus says,
shall I not drink the cup the Father has given me?
What cup's he talking about?
He's talking about this cup of God's wrath towards sin.
See, here's the reality.
If we merely speak of the cross as God's mercy
to us, and we sit around and we rejoice
and we talk about the old rugged cross
and it's like, oh, God loves us so much.
He's so merciful to us, and that's true.
But if we don't include
and couple that with the judgment that Jesus
averted from us on the cross, then it's powerless.
It's just kind of some sentimental feeling about the love
of God Shona through the cross to us.
But when we put it next to
and with the judgment that was due us, that was then
averted from us by Jesus dying on the cross, that's
where it gets its power, right?
See, the reality is that 2000 years ago, God's justice
and God's mercy met at the cross.
He didn't just wipe sin away.
He didn't just change the narrative. He paid for it.
He took the judgment.
The perfect sacrificial lamb of God went on that cross
and drained that cup of God's wrath
to its very dregs as it says.
He drank every last drop of it for those who believe.
He took it all away and said, now you're free.
And as that cup was poured out on him,
what was poured out of his body was his new covenant blood.
To forgive all of our sin
that put him on the cross in the first place.
His justice and his mercy met.
That's the good news that we declare.
It's not just bad news
and it's not just some sentimental feeling.
It's good news that fixes the bad news
of justice judgment.
Do us Jesus did it for us. Yes.
And so listen, I talked a lot about wrath
and it's not meant to, to scare, scare people.
The point is, I if you have repented,
and I'm not trying to create some like weird,
I don't believe I, I am I really a Christian kind of thing.
That's not the goal. If you have repented
and believed in Jesus Christ, one Thessalonians one 10 says,
you have been delivered from the wrath of God.
No more fear. If you are in Christ, you're free.
No more fear, no more doubt, no more question like, okay,
yeah, you're gonna feel different things,
but you can claim Jesus in my place.
That's my hope. Not whether I feel saved
or whether it took last year at camp or not.
It's Jesus in my place. That's my hope.
He delivers us from the wrath to come.
But listen, if you have not repented
and believed in Jesus, see the warning
here, this is what John 3 36 says.
Whoever believes in the Son of God has eternal life.
Whoever does not obey
or does not believe in the Son of God shall not see life.
But listen, the wrath of God remains on him.
That's the warning delivered from the wrath to come.
When you believe the wrath of God remains on him.
If that's you and you know
you've never believed, I invite you
to trust in this Christ who has drunk the cup of God's wrath
to the very fullest in your place
to deliver you from that wrath to come.
He's done it all. You don't have to be
trying to earn your way anymore.
You don't have to be exhausted by it anymore.
You just get to receive it for all that he's done for you.
That the cross life, death,
and resurrection of Jesus, that is the primary
wondrous deed that we recount as a church,
that we recount as believers.
That's why we give thanks to our God.
That's why we sing praises to the Lord God Almighty.
That's why we worship Jesus Christ, our Lord.
So let's do that now together, church, right?
If you're able, let's stand
and respond to these truths with grateful praise
'cause this is our God church.
This is who He is. This is what he does. He saves us.